Now that you're my superstar, no one else can take me this far
I'm flipping the switch, get ready for the star
Let's do the odyssey
Odyssey, odyssey, odyssey, odyssey
Odyssey, odyssey, odyssey
A new world calling out to you
Take a turn off your path
Das ist
Oh ja!
Verreckt FPS
Lieber flüssige Donau
Filme in ASCII abspielen kann und richtig meta ist es wenn ihr euch dann
Matrix anguckt und man quasi den ASCII Matrix Bildschirmschoner über eine
Videodatei in ASCII umgewandelt in seinem Terminal guckt. Das war so mal das
die richtigen Hacks war.
Die Mario Odyssey Musik ist geil.
Kommt nächstes Jahr eigentlich eine neue Katz-FPS. Ich war sogar jetzt schon im
Tierheim und hab geguckt und ich hatte mir auch eine ausgesucht aber die war
noch... ähm... ausgesucht, ne? So eine. Eine geguckt auf der... auf der Internetseite.
Wir müssen es jetzt noch mal machen. Musik ist übelst nice.
Oh! Oh, das ist nicht... das kann den Bildschirm nicht switchen, mein Meme-Tool. WTF.
Aber die hat hier mal ein anderes jetzt. Weil da wo ich da war, war die noch... ist die noch nicht aus ihrem
Häuschen rausgekommen und hat gefaugt wenn man rangehen will. Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay ich lasse erst mal ein bisschen in Ruhe.
Aber ich hol' mal auf jeden Fall wieder eine Katz. Easy.
Ein Meme-To-Ask-Converter wäre raus. Das ist nicht schwer. Das ist nicht schwer.
Wie gesagt, du kannst mit VLC und M-Player kannst du ohne Probleme jeglichen Film mit als ASCII Art abspielen.
Können wir das jetzt noch irgendwie toppen hier? Wir können auch das Aquarium unten anmachen.
Das ist... das ist voll ASCII-Power. Jetzt müssen wir noch den Papagei ein bisschen resize'en, dass der hierhin passt.
Oh, so ist es nice, oder?
Ja, aber die Papageien haben unterschiedliche FPS. Guck mal, links ist viel langsamer als rechts.
Was ist das für eine Musik? Das ist Mario... äh... der aus dem Mario Odyssey, Super Mario Odyssey Soundtrack.
Das ist das hier.
Jump Up Superstar.
Und nachdem heute Weihnachten ist, müssen wir ein bisschen Weihnachtsmusik anmachen.
Da kommen wir heute nicht dran herum. Aber wir gucken hier, gucken wir mal, wenn irgendwas nicht ganz so schlimm ist.
Weil Leute seid ihr auch in so unglaublicher Weihnachtsstimmung wie ich. Also so irgendwie gefühlt gar nicht.
Ja, ich auch nicht. Ich bin auch null. Juckt mich irgendwie überhaupt nicht, dass morgen Weihnachten ist.
Okay, ich wurde ja schon auf Twitter korrigiert. Morgen ist Heiligabend und nicht Weihnachten.
Aber das ist für die meisten Leute, die an Weihnachten denken, hauptsächlich an Heiligabend.
Bock auf Grillen? Mit Grills?
Gibt es eigentlich eine ReadMe, wie man das Meme-Tool-Setup? Das musst du nicht großartig set-upen.
Einfach starten. Das Problem ist, ReadMe ist schön und gut, aber das Tool ist ja nicht mehr auf GitHub fertig.
Ist ja nicht mehr online.
Jetzt muss man zu solchen ReadMe machen.
So, also Leute, es funktioniert.
Also das, was wir gestern versucht haben, was nicht funktioniert, hat mein JavaScript gefuchtelt mit der Kamera.
Das funktioniert jetzt. Wir haben nichts falsch gemacht. Das lag an Firefox.
Firefox buggt rum, wenn man es in diesen Modus hier packt.
Bei Firefox kannst du hier sagen Inspect und dann kannst du umschalten auf iPhone Simulator.
Sobald man das einschaltet, ist Firefox verbugt und es geht nicht mehr.
Der Witz ist, dass es auf dem richtigen iPhone aber funktioniert.
So, sag mal, mir fällt gerade so eine Sache ein. Ich hab jetzt doch so eine supergeile...
Was machen wir jetzt eigentlich? Was machen wir denn mal für Weihnachtsmusik?
Ja, das machen wir mal. Das ist nice.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was wir brauchen.
Ja, das, das machen wir jetzt. Achtung.
Das ist fast, fast bisschen wie die Musik vorher.
Damit kann man leben. Das ist nicht ganz so schlimm wie Utannenbaum oder sowas.
Ich hab noch jetzt so eine geile RGB Special Kick Ass Übertastatur.
Ich könnte mir ja immer eine Makro programmieren, dass ich zwischen den beiden Desktops wechseln kann.
Das müsste doch damit ohne Probleme möglich sein.
Das wäre schön, wenn ich einfach eine Taste drücken müsste. So hier Funktionstaste G1 oder sowas.
Auf der Tastatur und es switcht mir auf meinen zweiten Desktop.
Weil diese komische... Kommen wir mal im Ernst.
Steuerung, Windows-Taste rechts. Und dann reinklicken. Das ist vollkommen beknackt.
Und dann Steuerung Alt, Steuerung, Windows-Taste linke. Linke.
Na, das ist ja... Das ist ja klar, kannst du machen.
Sagt, ich schreibe, wenn die Musik zu laut ist. Aber es müsste ungefähr passen, ne?
So. Wie, wie, wie macht man da drinnen...
Bevor wir jetzt den Progangs anfangen. Lass mal gucken hier.
Wie macht man in dieser komischen Corsair... Wie macht man da ein Makro zum Desktop-Switchen?
Das muss doch, muss doch gehen. Ich mein...
Schau wieder! Okay, safe.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was er für Schmerzen hat.
Actions, Mute. Mute?
Moment, habe ich mich jetzt gemuted irgendwie? Hört ihr mich noch?
Hört ihr mich noch? Ja, ne?
Hab ich schon irgendwas ausprobiert? Weg damit.
Richtig.
Okay, wie macht man hier jetzt Makros? Action. Plus.
Die Software ist wirklich der allerletzte Shit, ey.
Start and record a Makro by pressing on the record button. Auf das da.
Okay. Und jetzt? So, bla, bla, bla. Okay, ich drücke jetzt mal ein paar Tasten.
Ah. Stop record.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt playe, drückt er ein paar Mal die Windows-Taste, hä?
Wie playt man das Makro? Play? Makro? Play? Play?
Wo ist der Play-Knopf? Brown oder Speed?
Wo ist denn der Play-Knopf für das Makro?
Mein Gott, diese Corsair-Software ist so scheiße.
Die Tastatur ist ganz okay, aber die Software ist so beschissen, ey.
Sag mal, sehe ich das richtig? Hat das?
Hat das keinen Play-Knopf?
Okay, das hat keinen Play-Knopf.
Wie? Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt auf den Key gebunden überhaupt?
Das ist... Alter, das ist mega. Kann ich das vielleicht einfach auf den Knopf ziehen?
Tracking-Drop? Ah! G2.
Okay, Achtung, G2.
Okay, es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert.
Er drückt mir noch das Tasten wie verrückt.
Welche Switches hast du in der Ducky-One-Skyline?
Äh, die Normalstop-Brown-Switches sind das.
Weißt du zufällig, wie ich die Meda-Tasten auf meine Tastatur zum Beispiel Play, Pause in Qt einbilden kann?
Äh, ich wüsste... Ich denke, da braucht man gar nichts Großartiges zu, oder?
Das dürfte doch standardmäßig funktionieren.
Okay.
Das war's für heute.
Ich wollte nur das eine Event löschen, das ist eine Oberfläche.
So, Add, Keyboard Event und jetzt machen wir, äh, jetzt drücken wir, jetzt drücken wir
V für View, so, dann machen wir mal ein Delay von 5 Millisekunden.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob das sonst funktioniert.
Okay, gucken wir mal, wie weit wir jetzt kommen.
Hallo?
Ah, nee, wir brauchen, wir brauchen längeres, wir brauchen längeres Delay.
Also müssen wir Alt, also müssen wir Alt-V drücken.
Also müssen wir Alt-V drücken.
Okay, Keyboard, das ist, das ist für, also das ist schon nicht schön.
Keep, Press, nein.
Press.
Wir müssen hiervon noch ein Delay machen, und zwar länger als 5 Millisekunden, weil wir brauchen,
Was meinten ihr, wie lang braucht der Switch so?
150 Millisekunden so?
Wie machst du das mit mehreren Desktops? Das ist ganz, ganz, äh...
Normal, das ist in jeder, ab Windows 10 ist das drin.
Guck mal, du kannst hier unten mit diesem, mit diesem Task View...
Kannste unterschiedliche Desktops hier oben anmachen und angucken und gedunsen.
Und Switchen mit Shortcuts kannst du zu Control, Windows, rechts, links, und dann kommt der nächste noch.
Okay, jetzt haben wir Key, Input Keys...
Was, Key V? Nein, nein, wir wollen...
Wir wollen, ähm...
Alt.
Dann...
Und dann wollen wir Release Alt.
Drei Stunden später haben wir wahrscheinlich auch unser...
Drei Stunden später hab ich auch Makros erstellt.
Key Release Alt.
Achtung!
Ah!
Okay, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns, das ist ja eine ganze Geschichte.
So, und jetzt muss ich zweimal Arrow Down drücken.
Keyboard Event.
Arrow Down.
Add.
So, mal gucken, wie weit wir jetzt sind.
Ah, ja, ja, ja, oh.
Fast.
Ähm, und jetzt muss ich noch Enter drücken.
Und dann bin ich...
Fertig.
So, Achtung!
Bam!
Was immer drin.
Nice.
Sehr nice.
So, nachdem wir das jetzt geschafft haben,
jetzt brauchen wir noch, jetzt müssen wir noch ein Zurück-Switched-Makro machen.
Aber ein Zurück-Switched-Makro sollte einfach sein.
Ähm...
Zurück-Switched-Makro kriegen wir hin.
Das ist kein Ding, das ist einfach nur der obere Teil, den können wir Copy-Paste und anstatt Arrow links, Arrow...
...Left.
Ja, ja.
Kann man das nicht kopieren?
Oh, come on, brah.
Warum nicht?
Kann man das nicht kopieren?
Nein, das darf man natürlich nicht kopieren.
Kann ich das Makro vielleicht kopieren?
Ha, sehr schön.
Okay, das heißt, den ganzen Schmodder hier unten brauchen wir nicht mehr.
So, Left-Arrow.
Left-Arrow, ja.
Ja.
Okay, und das binden wir jetzt auf Knopf Nummer 2.
Das heißt, mit 1 kann ich hinschalten, mit 2...
Moment.
Warum kann ich mit 2 nicht zurückschalten?
Ah, weil ich erst noch raus muss aus VMWare.
So Dinger nehmen immer Ausmaße an.
Da denkt man, das ist easy going.
Aber das ist es nicht.
Das heißt, ich muss vorher noch...
Was muss ich drücken?
Ctrl-Alt muss ich drücken zum Rauskommen.
Der Eax am Start.
Moin.
Designer-Karriere.
Beziehungsweise Photoshop...
...Bastlords.
Okay, das machen wir jetzt noch.
Dann ist aber gut.
So, hinschalten, Funds.
Zurückschalten geht nicht.
Zurückschalten muss ich was drücken.
Ctrl-Alt und dann das andere Kram.
Okay, das dürfte nicht allzu schwierig sein.
Insert-Events.
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt...
...Ctrl.
Aber wir machen das jetzt ein bisschen schneller.
Wir machen jetzt Zack, Copy-Paste.
Und jetzt Release.
Zack.
Oh, jetzt wird Optimized hier.
Optimizer am Start.
So.
Release.
Jetzt brauchen wir Ctrl-Alt.
Und Release-Alt.
Und der Release muss unten sein.
Und da.
Okay, das müsste jetzt klappen, ne?
Fast.
Ah, okay, man braucht einen Delay.
Ein kurzes Delay braucht man dazwischen.
Ups, ist das falsche.
Aber wir haben schon einen Delay.
Oh ne, quatsch, den Blödsinn müssen wir...
Ah, warte mal, den Kram müssen wir als erstes machen, Leute.
Okay, man kann es nur einzeln verschieben.
Okay, ich gebe zu, es liegt ein bisschen daran,
dass ich auch die Software nicht bedienen kann.
Aber ganz ehrlich, schön bedienbar ist sie wirklich nicht.
Äh.
Warte, ich blinke nicht mehr durch.
Ja, der muss doch oben drüber.
So, ne?
Ctrl-Alt.
Das können wir kürzer machen.
Noch mal 50 Millisekunden.
Wie wir 90 Leute zugucken,
vor allem, dass wir nur Makros erstellen.
Ha, bam, es funzt.
Desktop-Switchhors.
Okay, zu schnell darf man das nicht drücken.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Ja, wir haben es geschafft.
Pock, Alter, Pock.
Okay, hoffentlich speichert er das jetzt
und es geht nicht weg, wenn ich das hier zumache.
Ne, macht nicht.
Ha, sehr schön.
Ja, wir haben es geschafft.
Also ich finde immer noch,
der beste Treiber ist der von Logitech.
Da hast du nämlich
eine komplette Lua-Skript-Umgebung
und ihr kennt mich ja,
mir fällt es einfacher,
Logik zu programmieren,
anstatt sie zusammenzuklicken.
So.
Wie gesagt, es funktioniert.
Für alle, die neu dabei sind,
ich zeige mal kurz, was ich gebastelt habe.
Das ist das Programm von vor zwei Streams.
Ich hoffe, es tut heute wieder.
Gestern hat es ein bisschen umgebackt.
Und zwar haben wir ein Programm gebastelt,
um eine China-Gegensprechanlage anzusteuern.
Das ist ein Bild von einer
China-Camera-Gegensprechanlage.
Ich habe es abgeklebt, dass man mich nicht sieht.
Und wenn ich das hier drücke,
Test, Test, hört ihr es vielleicht?
Dann ist die
Gegensprechfunktion aktiv.
So, weil das soll unten an die Wand.
Das, was wir hier mit der
Windows-App gemacht haben, war ja nur so ein Test,
wie es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Denn die Sache ist die,
das haben wir uns gestern ja auch schon angeguckt,
wir müssten da eine
Mobile-App draus machen,
oder App in Anführungsstrichen, wir machen eine Webseite
als App verpackt.
Und damit haben wir ja gestern schon angefangen.
Und wir sind stehen geblieben.
Hier, ich zeige es euch mal.
Wo habe ich das Ding jetzt hin?
Moment, wo habe ich es denn überhaupt?
Documents?
Wo habe ich denn den Shit gestern gespeichert?
CD-Test. Ah, da ist es.
Ok, genau. Code.
Wenn man sein Zeug denn mal findet.
So, Leistung starten.
So, hier sind wir gestern
stehen geblieben.
So, und das funzt jetzt.
Man sieht, ja genau,
Firefox ist nämlich verpackt.
Das musste ich auch feststellen,
Firefox in diesem iPhone Simulationsmodus
verpackt.
So, und wenn man Chrome
jetzt umstellt,
übrigens kennt ihr das?
Das habe ich vorhin auf GitHub gefunden.
Es gibt eine JavaScript-only
Browser-Konsole.
Also quasi
das da
als
JavaScript-Library.
Was sehr praktisch ist, weil man ja natürlich
auf Mobile-Plattformen keine
Developer-Tools aufmachen kann.
Wieso nimmst du keinen Flutter? Ja, weil ich es nicht über einen App-Store
verteilen will. Ich habe ja gar keinen Apple
Developer-Account.
100€ im Jahr.
Und ich möchte was, was
halt überall drauf läuft. Da ist Browser erstmal am
einfachsten. Flutter hast du auch das Problem
ein bisschen gehabt, weil ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe
sowas, was FFmpeg-Bindings
und so angeht.
Also nicht, dass wir das jetzt brauchen würden, aber ich glaube
Native-Bindings waren in Flutter noch ein bisschen
schwierig.
So.
So. Jetzt schalten wir das
mal um.
Moment, warum
verschiebt es das denn jetzt? Ich will es jetzt
umschalten auf ein iPhone 6.
So. Und da
sind wir gestern stehen geblieben und ich habe mir das
heute Morgen nochmal angeguckt. Ist überhaupt kein Ding. Funktioniert.
Warum es jetzt nicht funktioniert, ist ganz klar.
Weil der selber nicht läuft.
Das kann nicht funktionieren. Aber
ich habe es heute Morgen
hingebastelt, dass
es, im Prinzip
hat sich hier nichts Großartiges dran geändert.
Das Einzige, was man machen muss,
weil das Restriktion von Apple ist,
man muss, wenn man hier so
das ist ein
Video Play Element
und da muss man
unbedingt reinschreiben
das da. Also die drei Dinge muss man
reinschreiben, dass es auf iOS funktioniert.
Und auch, dass es auf Chrome funktioniert.
Man muss reinschreiben Autoplay,
dass es halt automatisch losgeht, dass man nicht klicken muss.
Man muss Plays inline reinschreiben,
weil, keine Ahnung, weil Apple der Meinung ist,
das muss rein. Und das ist das Wichtigste,
dass es funktioniert. Man muss reinschreiben
Muted, weil
Chrome und
auch Safari auf iOS
haben die Restriktion drinne,
dass wenn man eine Webseite aufmacht,
dass die standardmäßig keinen Sound
abspielt. Und anstatt sie selbst einfach
alles muten würden, erlauben sie das Abspielen
erstmal gar nicht.
Logik suche ich in der Stelle da vergebens,
aber man muss das Video Element von Hand
muten. Und
na gut, man kann es dann wieder endmuten. Wir haben
sogar schon unseren fetten Endmute-Knopf hier unten.
So.
Und das nächste ist, also wie gesagt,
ihr könnt es mir glauben, es funktioniert.
Wir werden das jetzt auch gleich
uns angucken, dass ihr es mal gesehen habt,
wie es dann aussieht. Ich meine, die App ist nur wirklich
jetzt simpel. Du hast einen
Gegensprechknopf, den du klicken kannst
und du hast ein Bild von der
Gegensprechanlage. Das war's. Also
im Prinzip genau das, was wir hier
mal Proof of Concept-mäßig in unserer
Windows-App gebastelt haben, plus dass die
noch ein bisschen hässlicher aussieht,
jetzt halt im
Browser. Und...
So.
Aber, dass wir das machen können,
es gibt eine Restriktion. Und um die
kommen wir nicht drum herum.
Wenn man, weil
ich hab's euch, wir haben's ja im letzten
Stream auch gemacht, dass ich quasi vom
in das iPhone
sprechen konnte und meine
Stimme ist auf der Kamera rausgekommen.
Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon gebastelt.
Das war das hier.
Ich glaub, die zehnte Konsolen-App
ist es. Die hat die Geheimnis immer so geil namen.
Das ist alles. Mehr musste man nicht machen.
Man musste, man musste sich
den...
Genau, man musste den
Gegensprechkanal zur Kamera aufmachen.
Und dann hier, hier die Packages
abgreifen, Port 8, 7, 6, 5.
Und zur Kamera hochladen. Das war alles.
Mehr musste man nicht machen. Das war
wirklich easy an der Stelle. Das war gestern
wirklich easy. Ist kein Ding.
Es hat mich zwar gefühlt Wochen gekostet,
bis ich gecheckt hab, wie die Kamera funktioniert.
Weil so die
China-Style Websockets für
Arme dabei verwendet werden.
Ohne Websockets zu sein. Aber wir haben's
kapiert. Und das kommt da jetzt alles rein.
Die Sache ist,
damit das funktioniert,
also sprich das, was wir gestern nachgebaut haben,
auch mit dem iPhone, dass man
auf dem iPhone überhaupt
das Mikrofon
auf einer Webseite
aktivieren kann,
muss es
über HTTPS gehen.
Das will Apple. Das geht nicht anders.
Und jetzt kommt der
nächste Trick. Und da kann ich euch
mal wieder was zeigen, was
einem auch im Praktischen,
sei es Admin oder Programmierer
oder DevOps oder sonst was Alltag, was bringt.
Nämlich, es reicht
nicht einfach nur, wenn man
jetzt kann ich mal ein geiles Makro ausprobieren.
Es reicht nicht einfach,
wenn man nur HTTPS einschaltet.
Sondern
ähm, es muss auch
ein gültiges Zertifikat sein.
Und da wird's jetzt schon ein bisschen schwieriger.
Also sprich, wir brauchen
ein gültiges, wir müssen
HTTPS einschalten auf unseren Web-Server,
wo wir die Seite später hinlegen.
Wir brauchen ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Und jetzt die Frage an die Kenner.
Was ist die Voraussetzung dafür,
dass man ein gültiges Zertifikat bekommen?
Ein kostenloses.
Das ist jetzt eine blöde Frage.
Ich meine, wenn ich es sage, ist klar.
Ja, wir machen es mit Let's Encrypt.
Aber was ist die Voraussetzung dafür,
dass man Let's Encrypt verwenden kann?
Nein, ich spiele darauf an,
dass wir nur Domain brauchen.
Wir brauchen nur Domain,
die wir für Let's Encrypt verwenden können.
Und ich zeige euch mal einen Weg,
wie man das ziemlich simpel machen kann.
Wie man das relativ simpel machen kann,
ohne dass man sich erstens
ein Domain kaufen muss.
Übrigens, Domains sind heute wahnsinnig billig.
Ich habe mir ein Domain gekauft
bei, wie hießen die?
Pork Bun?
Das ist der billigste Anbieter schlechthin gewesen,
den ich gefunden habe.
Weil die hatten irgendwie Domain-Names.
Das kostet teilweise gar nichts.
Wenn man sich jetzt irgendwie ein Domain raussucht,
keine Ahnung, sagt mal irgendein blödes Domain hier.
Wubbel, wubbel, wubbel,
Punkt bis oder so.
Und mal gucken, was der Kram kostet.
Das kostet 5 Dollar das Jahr!
Das kostet nichts mehr, der Domain, ja?
Und das Schöne an diesem Anbieter ist,
finde ich,
zwei Sachen.
Die haben eine API, wo man DNS-Einträge
ändern kann über Curl.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Und die nehmen es überhaupt nicht.
Ja, Progas.
Progas.xyz zum Beispiel.
Guck mal, Leute!
Das scheiß kostet nichts!
Das kostet nichts!
Ich bin sogar geneigt,
fast geneigt, es mir zu kaufen, ey.
Progas.xyz.
So, und das Schöne bei dem Anbieter ist,
der nimmt es überhaupt nicht ernst mit,
was man da für Daten eingibt.
Also zum Beispiel,
wir tun jetzt mal so, als wollen wir das kaufen.
Wir machen das gleich über den kostenlosen Dienst.
Also,
wir machen das gleich über den kostenlosen Dienst.
ich,
also man kann hier wirklich,
du darfst hier wirklich, ah okay, man muss
einen Account erstellen, na dann nicht.
Aber, weil du kannst den größten Bullshit
eingeben bei dem Anbieter.
Und die akzeptieren das, solange du
bezahlst es auch mit PayPal oder so.
Und dann hast du eine Domain mit,
ich brauch die Domain nicht.
Das ist gut live.
Ich hab schon alles Mögliche,
was ich brauche.
Wenn die von euch einer kauft,
könntest ihr mir dann geben.
Weil es hat jetzt keinen Sinn, die im Stream zu kaufen.
Da muss ich jetzt PayPal und
Gedöns eingeben.
Aber die Idee ist, ist nice.
Ja, so.
Also, mal angenommen, man möchte
eine gültige Zertifikat, eine gültige Domain haben,
ohne sich den Domain zu kaufen.
So einfach so zu Testzwecken.
Ich meine, du kannst zwar immer mal 2 Dollar
ausgeben, aber da hast du Domain an der Backe
und so willst du nicht.
Ich finde, der beste DNS-Dienst, so für Dünn-DNS
Geschichten ist der hier.
DuckDNS.
Nennen die sich.
Das muss ich schon wieder ausmachen,
weil ich da mit GitHub eingeloggt bin.
Man kann sich einloggen mit einem GitHub-Account,
was doppelt praktisch ist.
Oh.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt mit GitHub.
Okay, da muss ich erst mal nachgucken.
Ja, ich logge mich mal bei GitHub ein.
Ich muss jetzt erst mal gucken, wie mein
Passwort ist. Das muss ich auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm machen. Passwort Store.
Ähm.
GitHub.
Sehr schön.
Sign in.
Ich mach mal sicher, ich mach mal
sicher, ah, hab ich gespeichert? Nee.
Ich mach mal sicher, zahl mal den Bildschirm kurz aus,
falls ich mich irgendwie vertippe mit dem Passwort
oder so.
Man weiß ja nie.
Okay, ich bin eingeloggt.
Ich mach mal wieder an.
Jetzt irgendeine Scheiße in die Zwischenablage.
So, ihr sollt wieder was sehen.
So, ähm.
Genau.
So, und ich finde, die beste Variante,
wie man das machen kann, ist mit DuckDNS.
Denn wir machen das Ganze, wie gesagt,
aber mit Let's Encrypt. Aber
also
das Ziel ist,
vielleicht nochmal erzählen,
das Ziel ist, dass ich auf meinem Raspberry Pi,
wo der ganze Kram drauf kommt,
im Endeffekt,
mach mal hier mal den Krempel zu.
Ähm.
Ich hab, ich hab Route Login
eingeschaltet.
So, also ich möchte auf diesem Raspberry Pi
ein gültiges
SSL-Zertifikat haben.
Welchen Passwort
hab ich seit Jahren?
KeyPass. KeyPass 2.
Das gibt's für jedes Betriebssystem.
Kann eigentlich alles, was man braucht.
Das hab ich seit Jahren schon.
Fahr ich auch ganz
gut damit.
So, wir machen jetzt mal ein neues, hier Zerts.
Neuen Ordner.
Okay, so.
Und nun, wie gesagt, wir brauchen ein Domain.
Jetzt können wir uns nämlich mit GitHub hier
sign innen.
So.
Das war's. Du loggst dich bei DuckDNS, loggst
dich ein. Mit
deinen GitHub Credentials.
Das ist super easy. Dann machst du dir ein Domain.
0.3d
0.3d.
Oh nein, externer IP geleakt.
Fuck. Ähm, egal.
Da machen sie immer
ne Panik. Alle.
So nach dem Motto, wunder was
jetzt da Schlimmes
passieren würde, wenn du deine externe IP
legst.
Naja.
Ähm.
Das ist doch nichts Schlimmes.
So.
Jetzt haben wir das Domain.
0.3d.
DuckDNS.
Und jetzt,
und jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Die meisten Leute denken, dass man für
dass man für Zertifikate
nen Web-Server
braucht hinter dieser Domain.
Und das ist nicht so.
Weil, ähm,
Let's Encrypt
stellt dir auch Zertifikate aus,
wenn du einfach nur über diese Domain verfügst.
Das reicht voll und ganz aus.
Das ist aber ein bisschen trickreicher.
Und zwar, als erstes muss man mal
Zertbot installieren.
Das ist ein Skript für
Let's Encrypt. Das ist relativ simpel.
So. Installieren wir erstmal
Raspberry Zertbot. Das kann jetzt ein bisschen dauern.
Warum ist denn da Datei kaputt beim
Fuck.
Warum gehen Dateien beim Download bitte schön
kaputt? Machen wir nochmal.
Der Pink des Todes
ist schon am Laufen. Ich kann nichts mehr downloaden.
Ok, jetzt hat's funktioniert.
Ah ja, wir können aber eine Sache machen.
Guck mal, wenn ich, ähm,
was war meine externe IP hier?
Das kann man, kann man jetzt zum Beispiel,
zeig ich das mal, kann man mal gucken,
was ich für Ports offen hab.
Kann man mit Nmap gucken und stellt fest,
ich hab nichts auf.
Sauerei.
Und ich antworte noch nicht mal auf Pings.
OMG.
Da wird's schwierig,
mit was Hacksort, würde ich sagen.
So, jetzt installiert das Ding erstmal
Zertbot vor sich hin.
Ich antworte nicht auf Pings, weil ich
irgendwie meinte, dass du mich gedetost hast. Genau.
Das, das ist es. Ja, ja stimmt.
Aber das Stream läuft noch easy.
Kein Problem.
Ich hab noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Aber das Stream läuft noch easy.
Kein Problem.
Aber die Pings sind ja auch nur eingehend,
deswegen ist ja kein Wunder, dass mein
ausgehender Stream noch funktioniert.
Ist ja eigentlich logisch.
Das ist also big brain.
So, jetzt hab ich irgendwann
Zertbot installiert.
Raspberry Pi Zero,
wirklich lahm.
Mit einer wahnsinnigen
Anzahl von einer CPU
und einem CPU Kern.
Guck.
Bam. Eins.
Eine CPU.
Übrigens, unter Linus kann man relativ
einfach nachgucken, was man für eine CPU hat.
So.
Da sieht man, was da drin ist.
Und da ist was wirklich Langsames drin.
Da ist ein ARMv6 drin.
Mit, äh...
Der Takt steht gar nicht dabei.
Weiß ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht, wie man
Features Java...
Weiß gar nicht, wie man
den CPU-Takt ausfließt.
Das geht bestimmt mit
irgendwie einem Raspberry-Kommando.
Die VC, äh...
Siehst du?
Ah, so geht das.
Das ist der Galva Flow beste.
1000 Megahertz.
Ach ne, hier.
Ach, kommt mal hier.
Coolenhart hat's ja wieder am Start.
Frequency 700 Megahertz.
700 Megahertz. Also das Ding ist...
Ich mein, dafür ist es relativ schnell, ne?
Aber insgesamt ist es wirklich
massive, huge, huge
slow ist das Ding.
So. Ähm...
Jetzt haben wir den Third-Pod installiert.
Und jetzt wird's
ein bisschen kompliziert, denn
normalerweise ist Let's Encrypt folgendermaßen gedacht.
Also zur Erklärung für alle, die
noch gar nichts da bisher damit zu tun haben.
Ich mein, ihr wartet ja schon mal auf
irgendeiner Webseite drauf, geh ich mal aus.
So, jetzt auf Twitch zum Beispiel gerade.
Und ihr seht ja, das Ding geht über HTTPS.
Das Ding geht beziehungsweise geht über SSL.
Dass das funktioniert, muss
auf dem Server ein Zertifikat liegen.
Und da gibt's zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder man stellt sich einfach selbst
ein Zertifikat aus.
Dann kann man zwar SSL machen,
aber jeder Browser
wird dir sagen, Achtung, also zum Beispiel,
wenn ich jetzt auf meine
ja, auf meinen Frontend
von der Firewall gehen will, dann krieg ich sowas.
Bam. Your connection is not private.
Weil das Zertifikat nicht stimmt.
Wenn ich
mit einem Browser auf irgendeine Seite drauf will
und das hier vorne, so das Häkchen, kommt alles gut,
dann brauch ich nicht einfach nur ein Webseite
mit Zertifikat, sondern ich brauch ein
gültiges Zertifikat. Und ein gültiges Zertifikat
krieg ich nur, wenn es eine Zertifizierungsstelle
ausgestellt hat,
der mein Browser vertraut.
Glücklicherweise vertrauen alle
großen Browser Let's Encrypt.
Und jetzt stelle ich mir für meine
hier angelegte
0.3D
Domain
erstelle ich mir jetzt einen Zertifikat.
Und normalerweise ist es so gedacht,
dass man hier dahinter
hier dahinter den Web Server laufen hat.
Wo dann
Let's Encrypt
die Zertifikate quasi hinlegt,
also man legt dort selbst, legt man
eine Textdatei hin mit einem Passwort.
Let's Encrypt schiebt dann da das
passende Zertifikat hin. Weil
dadurch hat man quasi bewiesen, dass einem
die Domain gehört. Das Problem ist, wir haben
keinen Web Server dahinter stehen.
Let's Encrypt unterstützt aber noch ein anderes
Verfahren. Und zwar ist das
DNS-Challenge nennt sich das.
Da muss ich
bei meinem DNS-Anbieter
ein geheimes Passwort hinterlegen.
Das machen wir jetzt hier alles live und stream, also so weit
zu geheim, muss ich ein Passwort
hinterlegen.
Wo dann Let's Encrypt auch dran erkennt, dadurch
dass der Eintrag da ist, dass mir diese Domain
gehört.
So, und um das zu machen
muss ich mal suchen, Zertboard DNS
Challenge. Aus dem Kopf
weiß ich nämlich nicht. Da, siehste.
Habe ich schon mal auf. Manual Plugin.
Genau, so funktioniert
der Kram.
Man muss dem sagen, hier
Zertboard, mach mir dann bitte
Let's Encrypt, mach mir bitte ein Zertifikat
für LUL3D.
DuckDNS.org
Preferred Challenge
DNS-Zert Only wollen wir haben.
Dann führ ich das Ganze aus.
Und dann sagt mir Zertboard
irgendwann sowas wie
Also
Irgendwann
E-Mail-Adresse. Ich will keine E-Mail-Adresse.
Geh weg.
Ja, genau.
Das muss man doch hinten dran hängen. Ich will das ohne
E-Mail registrieren. Das ist eh nur ein Test-Zertifikat.
So. Und jetzt
Zertboard geht jetzt zu Let's Encrypt und sagt
Stell doch mal ein Zertifikat
für LUL3D. DuckDNS.org
aus.
Und jetzt muss ich Let's Encrypt beweisen
dass ich der
rechtmäßige Besitzer, also ne, was
der rechtmäßige nicht, dass ich der Besitzer
dieser Domain bin.
Ja, wir stimmen zu.
Meine IP darf auch
gelockt werden, alles gut. So und jetzt
brauche ich, das ist der, das ist das
geheime, super
geheime Passwort von
Fuck. Jetzt habe ich es ausgeführt,
was ja noch gar nicht geht.
Gut, dann muss ich es nochmal
ausführen.
Das ist das super special geheime Passwort.
Was ich hinterlegen muss
bei DuckDNS.
Dass ich
der Owner dieser Domain
bin.
Wie lang das dauert?
Also ich weiß nicht ob du die,
erstmal ist es so langsam, weil es
auf dem Raspberry läuft.
Das ist ein Zero, das heißt der ist wirklich lahm.
Sondern, wenn du dir
früher ein Zertifikat bestellt hast, über so eine
Zertifizierungsstelle, das hat schon eine ganze Ecke
länger gedauert.
So und jetzt muss
ich, dieses, diesen,
dieses Geschwubbel
hier, muss ich einen Texteintrag
erzeugen auf
ähm,
ach die Musik ist vorbei, kann das sein?
Ist die Musik vorbei?
Was machen wir jetzt an?
Aber...
...
So, ähm, kommen wir mal
zum Thema zurück.
Jetzt muss ich als Textrekord,
TextDNS-Rekord, diesen Krempel
hier auf
DuckDNS hinterlegen.
So, und wie es da zufallen
so will, habe ich das vorher schon mal ausprobiert.
...
Und jetzt können wir die Domänen wieder löschen.
Wenn ich eingeloggt bin.
Jetzt können wir die Domänen wieder löschen.
So, weil wir haben nur ein gültiges Zertifikat gebraucht, sonst nix.
Wir brauchen die externe Domänen ja gar nicht.
So und jetzt muss ich euch noch mal kurz ausmachen, noch mal schnell was einstellen.
So, da sind wir wieder.
So und jetzt haben wir ein gültiges Zertifikat für die Domänen 03D.DuckDNS.org und das
Zertifikat liegt hier drinnen rum.
Jetzt natürlich die große Preisfrage, wie kriege ich denn für meinen Raspberry, also
sprich für ihn hier, der nur die Default Engine X Seite drauf hat, wie kriege ich denn
da jetzt irgendwie das Zertifikat hin und vor allem, wie kann ich meinen Raspberry dazu
machen, dass der denkt, er ist, bzw. nicht er, sondern, dass alle anderen Rechner denken,
er ist 03D.DuckDNS.org, das ist relativ einfach, ich biege einfach meinen lokalen DNS um, ich
biege meinen lokalen DNS um, das mache ich jetzt mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, weil
da muss ich meinen Router rumfuddeln und ich weiß nicht, ob man da irgendwas sieht, was
ich nicht will, dass man das sieht, d.h. ich biege jetzt meinen lokalen DNS um.
Das, wo ist es hier, Services, DNS, Settings, New Domain, 03D.Domain.DuckDNS.org, jetzt
also guck, ich zeige mal, ping, 03D.DuckDNS.org, achso ja, gut, geht nicht, not found, weil
wir haben die Domain ja wieder gelöscht, jetzt werde ich das aber umstellen, dass mein DNS
das auflösen kann und wenn ich das jetzt pinge, dann ist auf einmal 03D.DuckDNS.org
mein Raspberry Pi und jetzt alles, was diese Domain verwendet und das ist Massive Poggers
eigentlich, hat jetzt ein gültiges Zertifikat, das ist wirklich ultra nice, jetzt haben wir
nämlich zum Test ein gültiges Zertifikat am Start, was einfach da ist und das ist cool,
sehr praktisch, sehr, sehr praktisch, ich muss jetzt nur mal gucken, welche Keys wir
für was brauchen, warte mal, es gab ein paar Fragen im Chat, was ist das für ein Pi,
das habe ich schon beantwortet, mein Pi Zero hat schon ein Problem mit p-hold und nutzt
du p-hold, habe ich mal verwenden, das Problem ist, dass viele Webseiten hängen dabei, wenn
du manche Sachen nicht auflösen kannst, der Unterschied zwischen Adblocker und p-hold
ist, dass p-hold quasi die ganzen Werbe-Verteilseiten quasi DNS-technisch rausfiltern, dass man
die erst gar nicht auflösen kann und ein Adblocker entfernt den Kram halt aus dem Content,
das heißt, die Seiten funktionieren auch weiterhin und über p-hold hängen viele Seiten und verhalten
sich viele Seiten merkwürdig, das heißt, an sich ist eigentlich p-hold, finde ich persönlich,
ziemlicher Crap, an sich, also nicht von der Qualität des Projektes her, sondern von dem,
wie es sich auswirkt, ach das ist nicht mal so, das Zertifikat lässt sich jetzt nicht
mal verlängern, nein, das Zertifikat lässt sich nicht verlängern, das Zertifikat, na
doch, ich müsste einfach eine Domain wieder anlegen und mir ein neues Zertifikat abrufen
dafür, das ist kein Problem, aber das Zertifikat hält drei Monate, also für unser Test würde
ich sagen, ausreichend, so und jetzt muss ich meine Web-Server, ich habe hier ein EngineX
drauf, noch sagen, ähm, welche Zertifikate er verwenden soll und ich bin mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht ganz sicher, welche Sachen ich dafür brauche, also ich brauche schon mal
auf jeden Fall Keys, das wird wahrscheinlich mein Private-Sign, oder? Steht das da hier
irgendwo? Congratulations, your certificate and chain has been saved, your cert will expire,
hier steht ja, guck mal, es läuft aus, am 23.3., ok, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, welches der
Keys ich jetzt im Web-Server hinzufügen muss, muss man mal kurz ausprobieren, weiß ich
aus dem Kopf nicht, also gehen wir mal in meine EngineX-Config rein, Sites Enabled Default,
so und da aktivieren wir jetzt mal mein, ähm, das da, hier, cert, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok! Warum engines? Weil ich mit dem am besten zu Recht komme, da habe ich auch
ein paar von laufen, äh, ja und wie schon einer gesagt hat, auch als Reverseproxy,
Aber ich kann mir die config immer nicht genau merken.
Hier, genau so ist es.
So, und wenn wir das eingefügt haben,
dann sollten wir, wenn wir mit dem Browser drauf gehen, aktuell ist es so,
wir machen jetzt mal zwei Sachen.
Wir machen es, dass man sieht, dass es auch funktioniert.
Ich kommentiere hier den ganzen Knip, den aus,
und kommentiere mal ein Self-Sign-Zertifikat ein,
und mache SSL auf dem Engine X an.
So, System CTL Restart Engine X.
Da verschreibe ich mich jedes...
Wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Ah, okay, die Zertifikate gibt es nicht.
Ja, dann nicht.
Gut, dann kann ich euch nicht zeigen, dass es nicht funktioniert, aber...
Dann, dann nicht.
Dann machen wir gleich die richtigen Zertifikate hin.
Ich hau immer auf die Enter-Taste.
Es geht gar nicht anders.
So, wir haben SSL angeschaltet, wir wollen Zertifikate verwenden,
und zwar wollen wir einmal...
Ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken, was was ist.
Also ich vermute mal, dass das hier mein Private ist.
Moment.
WimRC
Set
Set Mouse
Das krieg ich zustelle, wenn Mouse-Modus im Wim an ist.
Kannste komplett knicken.
So, ähm...
SSL
Was mach ich denn da?
So, komplett.
Die letzte Kacknup.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, welches Zertifikat wohin muss.
So, ähm...
Probieren wir mal das da.
An der Stelle.
Und wo haben wir dann sonst noch welche?
Weißt du aus jemandem zufällig, welche Keys für was?
Wo man die hin...
Sonst muss ich jetzt halt mal nachgucken.
Live.
Nee.
Private Key, Private Key.
Ah ja, nee.
Zert 1.
Das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich.
Vermute ich mal.
Ich vermute mal, dass wir das Zert brauchen.
Für die Seite.
Und das Private Key für den Server.
Denke ich schon mal.
Nee, umgedreht.
So rum?
So rum oder andersrum?
Eins von beiden.
Restart.
Bam, hat funktioniert.
Jetzt gehen wir mal auf 03D.
DuckDNS.org
Und wir sehen...
Äh, na Moment.
HTTPS.
Und wir sehen, die Seite ist gültig.
Verschlüsselt mit Let's Encrypt.
So, und das ist praktisch.
Das heißt, jetzt ist sogar mein iPhone der Meinung,
ich darf.
Hier ist es.
Weil sonst darf ich auf dem iPhone nicht.
Weil.
Es ist ja im Prinzip, ist ja auch okay.
Also ich, ich verstehe das aus Apple Sicht schon.
Dass man sagt, wo Audio- und Videodaten abgegriffen werden,
möchte man auch, dass das, dass das ein gültiges SSL-Zertifikat hat.
Läuft das in-house oder auf einem V...
Äh, was?
Das hier?
Das ist ein Raspberry, da steht, da steht hier,
hängt an einem Kabel die Wand runter bei mir gerade hier.
In der Ecke.
Wir haben bloß den DNS umgebogen.
So.
Und nun zeige ich euch nochmal richtig was Geiles.
Und zwar, äh, wir machen uns mal einen Ordner im Heimatverzeichnis.
Nennen wir mal Pi.
Und nun ist es ja so.
Wir müssen unsere Anwendung irgendwie da drinnen platzieren.
Also sprich, das Ding hier.
Das Ding hier.
Diese, diese drei Sachen.
Die müssen wir jetzt in unserer, die müssen wir jetzt da auf dem Server platzieren.
Die Sache ist bloß die.
Ich will jetzt ja die Dinger nicht auf dem Server selbst, ähm...
Ja klar geht das bei dir nicht, die Seid.
Ähm, so, natürlich will ich jetzt nicht auf dem Raspberry selbst hier irgendwie HTML mit einem,
da rumfuddeln.
Und da gibt es was ganz Tolles, das nennt sich SSHFS.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, dass wenn es ums, ähm,
entwickeln gehen und, äh, entwickeln gehen, Debuggen und Netzwerkgeschichten
ist in der, in Linux einfach unschlagbar.
Und, äh, man kann zwar vieles auf dem Mac auch nachinstallieren,
aber das sind viele Sachen, die mitkommen halt ziemlich alt.
Guck mal an, wie alt die Bash Version ist beispielsweise, die bei Mac mitkommt.
So, und jetzt kann man sagen,
also hier, das ist hier mein lokales, mein lokales Linux.
Da ist unsere tolle, unsere tolle Draw.io-Geschichte von der App.
Und...
Ja, ich kann jetzt sagen, SSHFS.
Und ich möchte quasi meinen Raspberry Pi lokal bei mir,
das war wie ein HTML-Verzeichnis,
von meinem, ähm,
Raspberry Pi will ich lokal bei mir auf der Linux-Kiste verfügbar machen,
dass ich da editieren kann.
Und da kannst du nämlich einfach sagen, SSHFS.
Nimmst du die, die, die, die Uhr von deinem, also die Tradresse,
von deinem, äh, Remote, von deiner Remote-Kiste.
Das geht auch mit einem Server, der in Afrika steht.
Habt ihr das SSH-Zugang drauf?
War www.html und das mounten wir nach P.
Passwort eingeben, zack.
So, und jetzt bin ich lokal in meinem Verzeichnis drin.
Und ich zeig's euch mal.
Na, hier, welcome to NGINX.
Und ich schreib jetzt da einfach mal rein, ähm,
welcome to NGINX mit zwei Ausrufezeichen.
Gespeichert, reload, zack.
Wir haben jetzt lokal editiert.
Und es ist direkt auf den Server gesyncht.
Was natürlich beim Entwickeln super praktisch ist.
Ja, so ist das, ne?
Das ist doch, das ist doch sehr nice.
Also was heißt gesyncht?
Der hat das Fallsystem unten drunter eingehängt.
Ein bisschen wie OneDrive, ja, nur dass es halt, äh,
nicht über die Cloud geht, sondern direkt auf meinen Raspberry drauf.
So.
Und jetzt ist wieder nur noch einer da.
Gut, jetzt gehen wir hier mal rein.
Muss euch noch mal kurz ausmachen.
Ups.
Weil ich mal was nachgucken muss.
Oh, die Overwatch Musik ist fertig.
Äh, was wollte ich nachgucken, genau.
Ja.
Okay, alles gut.
Kann ich wieder anmachen.
So, und jetzt machen wir hier drinnen Visual Studio Code auf.
Jetzt halt hier auf meiner Linux-Kiste.
Jaja, bla, bla.
Schieben wir auf Desktop 3.
Und jetzt können wir hier drinnen wunderbar entwickeln.
Ähm, und es zynkt sich direkt...
Direkt auf den...
Das ist halt sehr nice, ne?
Guckt, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas mache, so bla, bla, bla,
speichern, reload, zack, ist es auf dem Raspberry.
Also, diese Seite läuft auf dem Web-Server von meinem Raspberry
und wir editieren hier lokal unter Linux.
Das ist schon echt sehr nice.
Ich muss mal meine Visual Studio-Config kurz rüber kopieren auf...
Wo hat man das, wo konnte man das Zeug hier sehen?
Help? Nee.
Config.
Nee, äh...
User, Con...
Ja.
Nee.
Warte mal.
Ich bin...
verwirrt.
Wo, wie ging denn hier nochmal das Zeug auf?
Wie kann man jetzt hier nochmal in die Settings rein?
Ah, da bin ich blöd.
War das nicht?
Settings...
Ah, Open User Settings.
Ist das jetzt neu?
Was, was ist die Wolke, welche Wolke?
Was?
Haben die das jetzt neu gemacht, wie man irgendwie Visual Studio Settings macht?
Das war doch sonst immer der einfache, stinknormales Text-File, oder?
Ja? Ist das jetzt, ist das neu?
Das sah doch nie so aus.
Ach, hier kann man es mir noch direkt öffnen, okay.
Ah ja.
Okay, naja, öffnet das mal was Neues.
User Settings, mal kopieren den Kram.
Ja, den Kram kann man immer noch reinkopieren.
Sehr schön.
Ja, nice.
Jetzt haben wir nämlich gleiche Schrift und alles Mögliche.
Machen wir mal, machen wir mal das Browser Fenster rechts.
Einstellen, zack, Konsole.
Ah, Moment, hatte ich nicht gesagt, unter Firefox ist es verbugged?
Werden wir gleich, werden wir gleich sehen.
So, okay, jetzt legen wir mal hier unsere Seiten an.
Und zwar brauchen wir unsere, so, Index, Index HTML.
Dann brauchen wir unsere, oh, dann brauchen wir, das Copy Paste, Copy Paste wir uns jetzt gleich einfach alles rüber.
Dann brauchen wir unsere Styles, CSS.
Und dann brauchen wir unsere Main.js.
So, und das kopieren wir uns jetzt alles mal hier von dem anderen Krempel rüber.
Styles, zack, Save, Main, zack, Save, Index, zack, Save.
Da sind wir.
Gut.
Auto Refresh Addon.
Problem ist, ich habe ja normalerweise den, diesen Live Server hier.
Das Problem ist, wir können das jetzt, also wir können das nicht proxien.
Wir müssen über diese Seite gehen.
Also wir bräuchten irgendwas anderes.
Gibt es da irgendwas Schönes?
Gibt es da irgendwie Live Reload Plugin oder sowas?
Was halt nicht die Seite proxien muss?
Suchen wir mal.
Live Reload, Live Reload Plugin für Visual Studio, Dev Server.
Oder hast du, Knäherbär, hast du hier irgendwie eine Empfehlung?
Das hier klingt eigentlich ganz, ganz zinnig, ne?
Was ist mein Programmierziel?
Eine App für Android und IOS.
Nein, eigentlich im Prinzip eine Web App für alle Plattformen,
wo ich meine billige Chinatür Gegensprechanlage mit bedienen kann.
Das hat prinzipiell schon funktioniert.
So.
Weiter im Text.
Wir, ja da installieren wir uns zwar mal was, installieren wir uns...
Ja, installieren wir uns mal dieses Live Reload Ding hier.
Mal schauen, vielleicht bringt das ja was.
Dann können wir nämlich tippen und...
Usage.
Das da muss in die Seite rein.
Oder geht das auch so?
Ne.
Dann muss man jetzt erstmal Reload, dann muss Reload.
Enable Live Reload.
Und jetzt?
Wie hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Man sollte den Kram in die Seite pasten.
Und jetzt geht das?
Ne.
Also, das ist eine komische Extension, die tut es irgendwie nicht.
Was hat der für...
Character encoding of HTML-Document was? Not declared.
Da meckert aber auch noch Firefox drüber gerade.
Ne, das Live Reload funktioniert nicht.
Das hier haben wir schon eingefügt, ja.
Ich mein, das wär schon nice, ne?
Das wär schon nice.
Kommentieren wir mal das aus, was es kaputt machen könnte.
Why?
Weil die Seite HTTPS ist wahrscheinlich.
Tja, ich fürchte wir haben schlechte Karten.
Vielleicht HTTPS.
Okay Leute, keine Ahnung, wie man das jetzt einfügt.
Meta-Charset in den Kopf.
Jawoll.
Also ich weiß, ich wusste doch, wir haben hier die HTML-Pros am Start.
So ist das nice.
Learn more.
Okay, das heißt man darf nicht.
Kann man da irgendwas dagegen machen?
Weil so ein bisschen Active Reload wäre schon recht nice.
Kann man das vielleicht in Firefox deaktivieren oder so?
Wie reparabel, gar nicht.
Ich vermute mal, da kann man...
Ich vermute jetzt einfach mal, man kann da nichts dagegen machen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich einfach Vorgabe sein von Firefox, dass das nicht geht.
Ich mein, wir können mal.
Wir können mal Chrome probieren.
Machen wir mal einen neuen Chrome, einen neuen Tab auf.
Aber da hat man wahrscheinlich gleich einen Schmerzen.
Ja, nee, darfste nicht.
Ja, das geht nicht, darf er nicht.
Ja gut, da können wir wahrscheinlich jetzt nichts machen dran.
Vielleicht hat ja einer von euch eine glorreiche Idee,
wie man Live-Reloading jetzt auf die Seite kriegen würde.
Logi als Live-Server.
Das Problem bei solchen Sachen wie der Live-Server ist,
der Proxy doch zwischenzeitlich Dinger.
Und das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall...
Die Seite muss von diesem Host ausgeliefert werden hier.
Das funktioniert sonst nicht ohne.
So Leute, ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
So, was machen wir jetzt für Musik an?
Wir machen jetzt wieder hier...
Was machen wir jetzt für Musik an?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?